using instant run is as simple as
pressing run or debug with the lightning
bolt displayed after making incremental
changes since your last build and deploy
on something simple and helpful most
people are satisfied with that hey Wayne
hey here you go what's that it's an
automatic dog feeder it makes it faster
and easier to feed your pets mmm nice
nice but we're engineers we're not
normal people uh Wayne oh yeah I think I
understand the mechanism for this and I
think I know how it works now huh so
let's take a look under the foot of
instant run and see how it actually
works
I'm ready Maya this is an Android tool
time deep dive and this is instant run
in Sarang minimizes the time taken to
build and deploy incremental changes to
your app when you run the debug variant
of your project rather than doing a full
build stopping the app reinstalling and
then relaunching it instant run tries to
only deploy changes avoid restarting or
reinstalling the app or even restarting
the activity there are three variations
to instant run a hot were warm or cold
swap understanding what does happen and
why we'll help you take full advantage
of instant run and to understand its
limitations and how your code change is
affected this is a very simplified look
at the Android build process your
manifest files are merged and packaged
along with your apps resources into an
apk similarly the Java files are
compiled into byte code and then convert
it to Dex files that are also included
in the apk first it adds bytecode
instrumentation to your class files so
we can replace code on the fly when we
update it later and it adds a new app
server class that will run within your
debug app in which the IDE will use to
transmit code changes that will be
applied at runtime Gradle also modifies
the application manifest to inject a new
application class this will proxy your
own custom application class if you're
using one and injects custom class
loaders that allow us to apply the
real-time code changes from now on when
you hit run Android studio checks if
there's an open socket to a server
running within your app and if so uses
that socket to confirm that there is an
instant run enabled version of your app
running in the foreground of that target
device you will then check the apps
build ID to make sure it's the version
expects before sending any changes while
you're developing Android studio
monitors which files have changed and
based on that runs a custom Gradle task
that creates a Dex file for only the
changed classes that new Dex file is
picked up by Android studio which
deploys it to the app server we inject
it into the running app the app server
uses the custom class loaders to load
and apply the updated classes but of
course the old versions of those classes
already exist in the running instance of
your app so Gradle has transformed the
updated versions to override the
pre-existing classes the app server then
uses the instrumentation that we
injected into our original classes to
delegate each method call to the new
override classes that we've just loaded
from now on each time the affected
method gets called anywhere within our
app the new modified version of the
method will get called instead if you
set breakpoints or look at your stack
trace you'll actually see the override
named classes methods called within your
stack okay so that takes care of our hot
swap so when do we need to warm swap and
what is a warm swap a warm swap restarts
the activity we do things like changing
resources the restart is needed to
reload the affected resources right now
that means changing any resource results
in all of them being repackaged and
resent but we're working on an
incremental packager that will only
package and deploy changed resources
that said warm swap won't work for
changes to resources that are referenced
within the manifest or changes to the
manifests itself that's because the
values read from the manifest are
determined when the apk is installed so
you need a reinstallation before those
changes can be seen so changing the
string resource used to define the app
name or drawable representing the app
icon aren't supported within instant run
so far we've looked at warm swaps to
update resources and before that hot
swaps that override methods within your
running app but what about structural
changes that can't be applied simply by
calling a method again like adding
removing or changing annotations fields
static or instant method signatures or
changing parent classes or static
initializers these cases require an
application restart using where possible
a called swap call swaps apply code
Changez by sending nude x-files that are
small slices containing only the
affected classes to the type device
before restarting the app as a result
called swaps dependent on uploading
multiple decks files so that requires
art which is only guaranteed available
on devices running Android 5.0 or epi
level 21 or higher the type device is
running API level 20 or lower and
possibly using the dalvik runtime
Android studio deploys a full apk
instant run tries to be clever but it
can't turn back time if you make code
changes that effect initializes that
will run when the application was first
started you'll need to restart your app
for the changes to take effect to
perform an incremental build and restart
the app click rerun if you want to stop
everything and redeploy a clean build
select run and then clean and rerun app
to stop the running app perform a clean
build and deploying your apk to the
target device so is knowing how it works
enough for an engineer let's check in
with Wayne I've replaced the mechanism
with a brillo board I think I can make
this thing internet-enabled that's what
I thought
in that spirit let's look at ways you
can tweak your use of instant run to get
the absolute most out of it instant run
is controlled by Android studio so you
need to start and restart your debug
instance from the IDE don't start and
restart your app from the device or
emulator or things will get out of whack
really quickly let's start by improving
those full build times by tweaking the
resources allocated to Dex you can edit
your projects Gradle dot properties file
to increase the maximum heap size of the
Gradle daemon to enable Dex in process
the default here is one gig so set it to
at least two and Dex in process will be
enabled allowing multiple decks
processors to run within a single VM
that's also shared with Gradle and
significantly increases build speeds if
you've increased the Java max heap size
in your module level build or Gradle
file from the default of one gig you'll
need to increase the Gradle daemon to
the M size accordingly thanks to support
in art for multiple decks loading you'll
get the best performance of instant run
by setting your min SDK version to 21 or
higher if your app supports earlier
platform versions it may be worth
creating a new product flavor that sets
your min SDK to 21 for your debugging
cycles
you can take full advantage of the
enhanced instant run support also
remember that any changes to the
manifest will necessitate a full build
and deploy cycle so if your build
process automatically updates any part
of the app manifest for example
automatically iterating version code or
version name consider disabling those
automatic updates in your debug build
variants instant run currently only
instruments the main process so if your
app uses multiple processes hot and warm
swaps on those other processes will
degrade to cold swaps or full builds if
you're targeting an API level less than
21 remember that hot swapping doesn't
reinitialize objects rerun class
initializes or modify data that's
already been saved or transferred
anything that has already run and won't
be rerun without the app restarting it's
not always possible for Android studio
to know when that happens so remember to
restart your activity or restart the app
when you know your changes will require
it if you're on Windows you may find
that Windows Defender real-time
protection is causing instant run
slowdowns you can get around that by
adding your project folder to the list
of Windows Defender exclusions as of
this recording instant run doesn't
support Jack instrumentation tests or
deploying to multiple devices
simultaneously but interneuron is
constantly evolving with the team
exploring new techniques to maximize the
number of cases that allow for a hot
swap and minimizing the need for called
swaps or full deploy and install cycles
and you can always find the latest tips
and tricks on optimizing instant run on
the Android studio documentation you can
also explore the cutting edge by
subscribing to the canary or beta
release channels if you're having
trouble with instant run or any Android
studio features let us know on Twitter
or Google+ I'm reto Meier and this has
been an Android tool time instant run
deep dive
yeah